Thank you everyone so much for coming
to today's food talks with undelete.
And we also have a professor of
gastronomy with us today here.
Um,
Angelique,
do you want to tell us a little bit about
yourself and why you're here and what
you'll be doing?
Well, um, and hold on. So we are
coming both from Hollins. Uh,
we work often together and
gastronomy and all kinds of flavors.
Uh, uh, I learned, uh,
in the beginning from a Peter
because he has, uh, restaurants, uh,
name.
So the Elbert's it's difficult
for you to that's true.
Yes, yes, yes. Uh, so it
started with the older, the,
the be aware of all kinds of flavors and
that's why we work or running long time
ago together. Uh, and now and all of the,
I'm one of the two female master chefs,
uh,
from about 150 miles of chefs.
I think I go a little bit here
because the sounds is a not so good.
Can you hear me good like this?
Okay, great. So in Hong Kong,
one of the two female master chefs
about, that's quite unique. Uh,
I hope in the, in the United States
where a lot of more female shifts,
well, what I'm doing is, uh, uh,
the art of creative thinking in slavery
and slave or mentioning and flavor
combinations.
So I tell you a little bit of story
about culinary creativity and then we're
going to make a flavor painting with
about 20 components so you can experience
all kinds of flavor
bearing play for matches.
We should maybe think,
oh,
I couldn't imagine that combination
has a whatever made in heaven.
So that's what I'm doing together with
Peter will explain why some combinations
have a special effects in your
mouth. And so, but before, uh,
we are doing that,
maybe Peter wants to tell a little bits
about himself and then we start with the
presentation afterwards.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you. She already mentioned a
lot. I have my own hotel and restaurant.
I developed a whole suite
of flavors. Siri, I think
flavor is something that you,
it's really tangible that we can measure.
And I've got a phd.
I applied a PG and flavor classification.
So it's the only classification
model off flavor in the world. Um,
and where do you work? So, um, we
have, we've found a way to really, uh,
describe flavor in objective terms.
So what I should dig is doing with
creativity actually is based on a very
factual thing. So thinks that
Google's much like, because a,
there is real algorithm,
there was a real model,
there's real thinking
objective thinking behind it.
So what she is doing is
showing beautiful penny.
She's going to create a beautiful
painting right here. Um,
and then the new may time I will
discuss a little bit on the objectives,
objective side of it. So, um, these are
the ground rules with flavor composition.
So that's what we want to show.
Okay.
So first I'm going to start with a
little bit of presentation about creative
thinking and about not
about dream storming.
That's about a note about brainstorming.
What about dream storming?
And then I'm going to make the painting
and afterwards we do a little bit of
culinary mindmapping so you'll be able to,
uh,
can make your own size of combination
in a very, in a couple of minutes.
So who loves to cook? Okay, well,
I'm so happy. That's the reason
why you're here. I say, okay,
okay, that's fine. Um, for
me the sky is the limit.
And uh,
the,
the story about creative thinking is very
important before you go in the flavor
matching because a lot of times we say,
okay,
maybe it's not possible or we
see a lot of issues on the roads,
maybe it's too expensive and I think
it takes too long time and we have all
kinds of reasons to do something.
No nothing,
don't let do that. So for
me, the sky's the limit and
uh,
in thinking is to creation in doing this,
the feeling and the
making is the learning.
And I want to tell you a little bit of
story, uh, what temps it happens to be.
Uh,
already 14 years ago I saw a hot air
balloon and that was in my car and I was
dreaming a little bit and a jazz music
on the background and I think, hey,
Eureka,
the balloon is actually a hot air,
often very big hot air often do.
We
had a experience in a hot
air balloon? Yes. Okay.
You have once been in a hot air
balloon. Yeah. Everybody almost. Oh,
that sounds great.
So,
so imagine the balloon
is a hot air often oven.
So what will happen when you put slumps
again at like a sea bass or a particular
or some muscles or Zoma
Paprika. Would it, will it,
will it be kooks well,
I can say so myself at the
same moment now at the,
because too dangerous or uh, maybe
somebody else did. It's already,
but I stay in my dream and my
fantasy fantasy setting. Oh,
when it's possible,
then we can make a restaurant with the
most wonderful view you can imagine
around smaller villages
and a small rivers.
You go low and you go high.
So you have the restaurant with rich.
Wonderful.
And uh,
I keep on dreaming and then I called
the a guy from a company, I said, Hey,
can I ask you something?
Is it possible to boots
to go once with you?
It's a balloon and put something in.
It's the shame was a little bit
quiet at the moment. You say, yes,
come to my company and we go
together in the air. And we,
let's try it.
So I had the all small bags with
a small chickens and the sea bass,
and then they fill the
balloon with the cold air.
And then we walked in the balloon and
it puts all the older small bags in the,
yeah, in the side of the balloon.
And then we go up and then we say,
all right here,
do you smell already?
Something that's too big to
smell something. And then, um,
after it's, uh, the idea grows,
that's what happened. Yeah.
You get used to the idea and then the
idea of getting normal and then you want
more.
So I say we can go with one blue,
but what will happen when we put three
balloons together and we have 50 persons
in three balloons and we go up
about one and a half kilometers,
I don't know how many feet
it is, but it's high. And um,
uh, and we do a three
course menu, uh, in the air.
They say, well, it sounds wonderful.
And then we get more used to the rd or,
and then we say what we do,
we put two chefs on the top of the blue
and they go up sending only outside and
give me the main course.
Yes, that would be wonderful.
So we are all so exciting. We
all really exciting saying, Whoa,
that would be wonderful.
And that we jumped out of the balloon
to make the dessert in the metal before
the balloons are lenders.
Sounds wonderful. Do you think,
do you think this is real?
Do you think has happened?
That was a good attitudes.
That's great. Yeah.
It's Google. So, uh,
for me, uh, brainstorm, it's not anymore
a brainstorm for me. It's a dream storm.
It's like a hyper creativity.
And then you have to be sometimes high
creative too to be different or to reach
some things you will never
talk to you could reach and um,
no, Lucas is going to, uh, show the movie.
Yeah.
Of the three blues
connected with 50 persons,
one and a half kilometers,
high,
three course menu on
one and a half a hour.
So it's a, that's me. It's
a little bit young garbage.
Okay. So these are two chefs who
are going on the top of the balloon.
That was the biggest balloon
of that sign for 24 persons.
Okay.
Three balloons connected.
And we go up,
this is very short movie and this is
about one of the asking me these high.
He's on top of the balloon
and the temperature and the balloon
is about a 90 degrees Celsius.
So you have to need to convert her to uh,
to put it in the,
okay. So he's um, you can imagine
two shafts on the top of the balloon.
When the balloon is a already hall filled,
they go up and there is uh, uh, on
the top of, there's a small opening,
they can check how my, uh, food is
and this is the system from
one bloom to the other balloon.
So we had one kitchen balloon at two
restaurant balloons in one kitchen,
balloon efforting was
cooped and then it go,
it's go down with a police system and
then it goes through the other balloons
where it was a chef to
prepare it for the guests.
So here is far three
course menu for 50 persons.
Then, um, he had, uh,
had to move on the top of the balloon
because it was very hot, you know,
cause when he was standing still,
it was a, so he had to move around.
So this is the first day CDs is a Dorado,
which a few undergrads and cucumber.
Okay.
It's wonderful.
That's was so high.
And now he's going upstate me
with the main course only outsides
and the he say, oh my God, it was so
hot upstairs. There it was so worth.
It was the second guy.
And then
after, uh, the main course,
it was a chicken stuff
where it's a duck and um,
we serve with some mushrooms
and some green asparagus salad.
Then they disconnect the three blues and
you see each balloon is going and then
they jump outs, the gym park to
prepare to prepare to desserts.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you Lucas. Okay. For me,
this is the example of believing in every
rd or you do you have in every dream
and uh, go on, take action.
Because when I did say to that's RDA
from this might be too dangerous,
or I call an insurance
company and they say, Oh,
you have to insure yourself. Well, uh,
what will happen when
the balloon will crash.
So it's not necessarily not necessarily
to insure yourself, you know?
Huh.
But for the other guests also notes.
Okay. So this is me and my kitchen.
This is my view from the
kitchen with a lobster salads.
Nice view. I, this is the kitchen. It
looks if the balloon is putting their, uh,
in the Alps, but this is actually a
picture made from another balloon. Uh,
it was in Austria and we made a triple
four hours and I could make a about,
uh, uh, I made it 12 dishes, uh,
above the offs was very exciting.
This is above the clouds. So you know, uh,
the sun is shining above the clouds and
then you go to the clouds and then she's
very quiet and then you
eat your lobster there.
So, um, for me,
everything I do is coming route
of my hearts and I believe in,
that's already a long time ago.
I was a chef with a Michelin Star,
uh, in the restaurants.
And then I felt, okay, uh,
do I want to do this my whole
life? Oh, yes, maybe, but
not owning the restaurants.
So,
uh,
my dream was to tell more about flavors
and to travel and to do crazy things and
to give experience to people,
but not an experience because it's
like a marketing, but experience,
which is real and authentic experience.
And for me it's that experience,
economy experience is economy,
but only when it's a
meaningful experience.
Uh, so this, these are the
most mentions idea killers,
uh, like, uh, uh, it might
work in other places,
but not here. And since this is the,
the, the diverse one, uh, since,
since I would say, since man,
you are the experts, you know,
when you say that to someone,
they say, oh, next time,
I don't want to mention my idea.
So
okay,
you aren't familiar with this,
but the idea chemist and the opposite
of the old, the idea can, it's rd,
id of boosters stuff,
just, just do it and uh,
go experiments.
So don't shoot.
You don't have a license
to kill odd years.
This is my message always in the kitchen.
So you have to try a lot
of things also to, uh,
everybody has a flavor reference and
a flavor memory from your childhood,
from the soup your grandma made orders to.
Uh,
and when you love food,
uh, is your memory. And uh,
therefore it's important to,
uh,
trying a lot of things so
you can make it even bigger.
Well, no. Um, it's about temptation. Um,
and I want to tell you about a carrots.
Okay.
Just a simple carrots. And if
I look to the carrot think, oh,
you're just a carrot.
You see the, the rabbits,
he's laughing to the carrots because we
are only using the carrot as a senate or
in the soup or made us to
actually do in Hollins. But,
um,
uh,
the challenge is to make a
carrot like golden carrots.
Yeah. You know, like, like gold.
More to give much more value.
And when
I'm also chefs and the restaurants and
I have tomato bake a new menu cards.
Ah,
it was until three o'clock in
the night and I was thinking,
oh,
I had the dish.
But I sometimes I missed
that one little accents
which make a dish can make very
special, timeless, you know?
So sometimes you want a restaurant
and say, ah, this is very nice.
And another time you say,
this is wonderful, you will
never forget the flavor.
Do we have to experience sometimes
it okay any other time or say, Oh,
I wish I could go back to that, to that
restaurant and, and experiences again.
That's what I need. I mean, as a chef, uh,
I think it's important
that you create dishes.
That's a guests will come most
remember and they will come back for.
So I was always thinking,
thinking, thinking all,
sometimes you have it at a
split seconds. You say, okay,
I miss a baby.
A little bit of lemon or maybe
a little star on his or some,
uh, maybe some seaweed, whatever. Um,
but when you make a France,
France,
oh, sorry, go back.
When you make a, uh, let me see. I'm
missing some. So can you make inspiration?
French spoons. Oh, world of
possibilities of flavors.
It's open.
It's one logical thing is most people
can only remember certain things from the
short memory. So when I
show it to you, carrots,
just
think of carrots,
which are the best snake of
French over carrots. Yes.
Name Sir. What do you eat? Ginger.
Thank you. Come on lemon. Thank you.
Cinnamon. Yeah, it's great. It's a
great match. Cinnamon and the carrots.
Garlic. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We already here.
What's about to 30 people
with Fort Things? Okay.
Cumin. Oh, but what did
you say? Elements. Yeah,
Laurel. Great. Sweep the ferrets. Okay,
Miss. Yes. So you know what is
happening now you'll have to think,
oh, oh. And just the, the, the, the,
the things we know where it matches with
the carrots are in the front because
maybe you've just tasted or
you had just a Senate bits.
Then you have to search for more.
And that's the good thing to know.
And creativity.
That's when you have that.
You can just remember seven things.
So when you say,
um,
burst of inspiration coming home
is four chefs sells time memories,
uh, from dishes. Uh,
you already eat or from your
family or our restaurants.
So mark has cookbooks,
magazines, internet, television.
But it's for a chef. It's very important
to let you get inspired by the season.
We'll take the best care,
Doris, a wonderful carrots.
I go and my mind, uh,
traveling to see, I think, oh,
what's,
can the see offer me in this season?
Maybe a nicer squids or maybe so
anchovies or so I'm looking for flavored
switching. Oh, the carrots will be
happy from that. So if you are a carrot,
what makes you happy? Yeah,
that's the way chef thinks.
I'm traveling in my mind to a lab or to
fashion. Fashion is a big inspiration, uh,
for a matching flavors and colors.
So later on I will make the carrot
with a very concentrated tomato puree.
Then you see that the
colors can be inspired. Um,
just to look around you
to the section or arts.
It's not only the colors art,
but it's also when you look at
this painting, Oh, what's real?
This painting tell you, uh,
you see a lot of, uh, deep,
you'll see a lot of colors,
warm colors and cold callers.
And then if you take a look
for a couple of minutes,
then you get some emotion.
And where you trust on that emotion,
you can use it in your
flavor combinations. Well,
so now again,
you love to cook
and then we think again of the carrots,
what can I do with the carrots?
These are preparations,
these are all kinds of things
I cannot remember. I says yes,
I can also remember seven, maybe 10. Uh,
when I say, oh, okay,
it's a good idea to graze or carrots
or two fermented or to put it on the
barbecue or um,
I marinaded or deep fry it or make
it in a proper yachts, you know,
in the foil with some garlic and
oil and rosemary or I injected,
oh yeah, of course. You know, you can
inject a carrots. Ah, so when I have a,
uh, like a, um, a needle,
I could put it in and
I know, or a bit, uh,
sorry. Yeah. And then,
then good old flavors to inject
it and then put it any often.
And then all the aromas are going
between the carrots or I can smoke it.
Okay.
So there's a lot more possible when
you make the inspirations visible.
And these are just a word
cloud sell. So, uh, you know,
word clouds, word clouds
on the Internet. For me,
your word clouds is, um,
a lot of inspiration.
Um, four techniques.
These are preparations.
Techniques can make a buffalo out froma
or a cream from a carrot or could make
an ice cream or a soup or sorry,
rock.
I can make a spring roll
and there's Puma Flan.
It's so much I can do
to make this carrots,
to give this carrots so much more value.
Um,
now the thing is I can travel
in my minds to another culture.
So this is my loco.
And uh,
while you travel and you
go to the markets, you was
going through the markets,
everybody,
okay?
And then you see all the flavors and the
spices and herbs and the fruits and the
veggies. And then when you close
your eyes and you go with your,
with the carrots, you go to the
markets in Marrakesh, we say, oh,
okay, a sort of star. I
knew it was an assault,
the lemon and the sort of
grapefruits and oranges.
She's so many things. That's what
you can do, your imagination.
But sometimes we say, oh, on a
little bit crazy, we laugh about it,
but it's really, uh, it's brings
you a lot of our dealers to, uh,
to travel in your mind to conflicts
where you've been a concrete Smith's you
with inspires like,
uh,
when we think of a carrot and we want
to combine it with Chinese ingredients,
where do you think of
Chinese kitchen?
Yeah.
Soy Sauce. Oyster sauce,
rice, wine, rice, vinegar.
More Chinese, Chinese. Your
child from China. Oh, sorry.
Okay. Garlic. Yeah.
Yeah. Johnny's kitchen.
Come on Johnny.
Johnny fix you.
Yeah.
Cinnamon also.
Nice. Yeah. Yeah. Well
we go along now we go to Eataly
who has been in Italy. Okay, great.
So when we think on a carrot and Italian
kitchen, where do we obtain golf?
You tell me kiss.
She may be close by in your flavor memory.
You're telling me kitchen
come home, red wine, red,
red wine, red wine, basil,
tomatoes, this olive oil. Come on, go on.
You can do it. Parmesan
cheese, prosciutto.
Porcini sync of what?
Fish.
You know from the Italian
kitchen you have often on a pizza
or Oregano and Chavez.
So Parmison, prosciutto,
anchovies, sardines.
It's all Italian kitchen,
Italian cuisine.
What will happen when you
templates for Jews, the carrots,
which all of these ingredients
get a different carrots. Yeah,
so that's a little bit my message.
And uh,
for the painting,
this is the painting in my head from
all the traveling I did from all the
countries think, oh, I have the
character to tomato and I have to ginger.
And she reads, I have to Vodafone
scars and saffron, a fennel seeds.
I have the deal and I have even the coffee
beans. When you crunch coffee beans,
you have a lot of flavor.
Well,
what will happen when you make a carrot
cake and put some coffee flavors.
Okay,
so this has happened in my head as a chef
and these are the dishes.
Then I just made this a
yogurt ice cream with a roast.
It's a orange shirt, Publicar
with mango and the chips of, uh,
carrots, tips of carrot,
but not in deep fried,
but to draw heights.
And you often buy 70 degrees.
This is the inspiration from
Marrakesh with, uh, with,
uh,
the carrot salad with lentils,
with a reduction of orange juice
and some also her nudes. You know,
Russell nudes, the best spice
mix from a despise men there.
Um, and so, uh, take care to piece
to piece these cream.
And so mint.
So this is just a combination in
my inspiration from Marrakesh.
Okay. This is a severe
issue with Kima, uh,
with, uh, Korean or
this is the Chinese inspiration.
This is with tuna and a
role with a Ferris thin,
a carrot with buys,
seaweeds and the major
addressing, uh, from, uh,
reduction of orange juice,
Tempura of carrots.
This is very important in this
dish you have from one carats,
you have, uh, for preparations.
So the whole carrots wasn't the often.
And then all the,
uh, uh, uh, all the juices and
the carrot are caramelizing.
And then I could it's and it's,
um,
it didn't touch any water.
So it's full of flavor.
Then I made around the carrots.
It's a marinated carrots julienned.
Then I made a mousseline
of the rest of the carrots,
which some olive oil and some lemon
juice because lemon is bringing all the
flavor more intensified,
more alive and then a crunch.
So when you think of these flavors
and you have a speech of the carrots,
you have a smooth mouth feel of the cream.
You have a balance of the sweet and
sour from the American Mary Nation. No,
the marinated carrots.
And you have a crunch.
So this is what you can
do with one ingredients,
one veggie to should use it.
These are all veggies,
marinade it and rolled up.
And this is the same.
Okay.
Well before I'm going to make the
painting. Um, this is a flavor graphic.
Uh, you can make a flavor
graphic graphica yourself. Uh,
think, oh, okay. I using
aren't even in this case. Oh,
which spice I do like which
spices I can make a match with,
uh, uh, with an NDA.
And what can I do with the men?
We cannot remember this.
So when you draw it and make your
own word cloud or a minus, oh,
worlds is going open. Yep. Okay.
Sorry. Next one. Excellent. Yup. Okay.
Um,
this is the last heat before
I'm going to make the painting.
Okay. Let me talk about the
success factors in Alaska. Peter,
here you go. Stand here. It's
a little bit better. I have,
uh,
Peters will tell more about the success
factors because it will help you every
time when you go,
this is the restaurant eat a dish or you
make your own dish because there are a
couple of, uh, it's not
rules, but a couple of, uh,
ah, some position Brussels compensation
rules accomplishes. And why you,
why you will hear this,
you will never forget it because it will
make every visit to a restaurant and
every dish you mate, it's still
be made difference. Nope. Okay.
So the thing is I want you to,
you're saying you need imagination
with them and imagination.
You've got all these wonderful combination
of things and then there is also kind
of a theory. So you need to kind of
a theory to bring it all together.
And that's what, uh, what, um,
there's this slide shows is for one those
because it's very special. Umami is a,
of course one of the, it's called
one of the basic flavors. Um,
your mommy is a very rich
family or four flavors.
What is one of the,
um,
culinary success factors is
that your mom should be there.
So if a dish Mille lacs your mommy,
there's something missing. This
what, what, what Lashley could sing.
So knowing about your
mommy is very important.
This is the other important side of it.
Uh,
knowing about what every
component does in the Tisch.
So we think that flavor is basically
about my field and in mouth feel they're
ours. Those three different
forces. One force, it's one forest.
We call contracting a Mattel. We receive
it has everything to do with salt,
with the ascendancy, with sour. Um,
thanks a contract to your mouth.
That's why we chose the word contracted.
Another substance is called
another direction or the
force is called a coating.
And this is about all the
fats and all the shivers.
And everything that really
leaves a layer behind your mouth.
And then there is another vector,
another force that's
called drag or drop a,
which is basically the crunch or
everything that has a texture,
things that you can chew on, things
as you can bite off, things like that.
So these are different forces.
And the,
this is basically the basic of
every flavor throughout the world.
When I was in Beijing,
I gave a master class and BG and
then all these Chinese people exactly
understood more what I was talking
about within their cultural frame,
within their cultural frame of flavor.
So it's very important,
I think to realize the flavors.
It has a real structure
and I call them vectors.
And these are real vectors with
forces behind them. Of course,
we don't have a measure for these forces.
That's what we need to develop,
will be wonderful to have a scale
where we don't have the skills yet,
but I think these skills
will be developed. Um,
smart people at Google should
be able to do that for sure.
But this could be the base of,
of any algorithm or flavor.
So now we're going to go back to
practice, um, in building the painting.
Yup. So actually, okay. Um,
so I will tell every time if it's
coaching or worth trying or, Yep.
So this is the carrot, a carrot, sorry.
This is the pumpkin and a sweet potato
in the often lot of Bailey's and garlic
roasting, roasting, roasting,
then are pureed foods.
And that's a little bits.
It's not sweet, but it's,
um, yeah, it's, it's, it's coating,
but it says flavor with a little
white wine vinegar to lift it up.
Excuse me. And this will be
kind of the basic for the paint.
Oops. Oops. Okay. So coaching,
right. I'm gonna ask some witness.
They want to help me.
You're going to have to go, you're
going to be able to taste everything.
So you will see that there is this a
bit of acidity in it because otherwise
you'd would be to coating.
So the acidity,
it works as a countervailing power
within the coaching within the door,
right?
Yeah. That's perfect. That's
what competition is about.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
it's a little bit sooner because I did
made it this morning. So, uh, okay.
I do it a little bit different
now. If you stay here, we,
we'd give you some other,
uh, so you put big dots.
Take your time,
take a nice job like this.
Oh yes.
Okay.
Just on every plate.
Some.
Okay.
Okay. No, I have, um, this is a occurred.
Cool. What's, um,
for your a yogurt I might occur trough
with some Miso and missiles from uh,
and soybean paste and
fermented soybean paste.
And it's,
every Japanese from a family has its own,
uh,
Michelle,
so it's a little bit salty and it's a
very nice combination together with the
Kurds.
[inaudible]
great.
Again, a coating substance. All right.
Taste it. You will find the
acidity. So that balance of way,
a bit of the richness of the coating.
Yup.
That's the balance you
find within the substance.
So just this nice dose
and line.
And this is some Kurtz, uh, to, uh,
but it's mixed with saffron
to make it some more, uh,
mystics see
[inaudible] success factors.
For instance, at Google,
I'm the London and Paris and Zurich.
And Dublin. We work with Google chefs,
we develop dishes, but based on
the color and her success factors,
then they were served.
And then we asked just which one,
three alternative do you like best.
And then every time you find that
the ones that have the culinary,
our success factors are
found to be without any
inflammation naturally the best.
It's very interesting to revalidate and
reevaluation of these connect success
factors and presentations
is a very important one.
So the way things look, the presentation
of a dish to name you give it,
they should test try it
was all a part of flavor.
It's often forgotten when people think
that flavor is sweet, sour, bitter,
et cetera. But this is
much, much, much more.
And you need to take everything
into account to really
understand what flavor is
about. So the name presentation,
color is an important aspect of it.
Balances and important aspect.
Uh,
smell is an important aspect and your
mommy is one and a very identifiable,
identifiable flavors. There's more so,
and then you need a balance in my field.
Differences in that. These are all,
let's say the coating substances of you
will find that we need more to make a
nice balance and a nice dish
or a canvas or a painting.
Yup.
Then we have the tomato,
a tomato with a,
yeah.
Mixed together with the sweetness of the,
Oh,
sweet potato and the pumpkin
tomato is a very special ingredient
because there are many flavors within the
tomato is you have a, let's see, already
harvested tomato or a, an unripe type,
then the acidity and the
darkness will be there.
But when you have a very rich
tomato, which is a, a harvested late,
then of course it will be
much sweeter and much Richard.
So it's very important to
look at what type of tomato,
half for the effect that you want to use.
Do you want to have something sweet?
Do you need it? Riper type of tomato
in their suite. Sweeter one. Then, um,
if you're just wanting to talk
to us with their, yes, it is.
Okay.
Okay. Then we have a very wonderful
ingredients. He was, you will smell.
It's so volatile hall.
It's a fermented, uh,
spices and veggies from
the Indian kitchen,
like a,
like a onion,
garlic curry leaves and
is very strong. So, uh,
I, I'm, he gets until
a 40 degrees Celsius,
mixed it with skin flora since flour and
olive oil and it's still be connected
connecting cause it's not
spicy but it's full of flavor.
You say part of the second
factor factor that I mentioned,
the smell of our dish is very important.
Or using an oil like this,
you have a very rich flavor components
and you will notice that within seconds
everything will smell like the of here.
So it's an important aspect is fine.
Split shot already have it in my nose.
Your House.
Okay.
Okay. Then for the crunch, a juicy crunch,
we use the leaves of the
Andes and you can use a later.
I like a kind of a spoon.
And then with the Endif if you
pick up the creams, like a crutch,
we need a crunch.
Piedra
okay.
So also this is about it all, all uh,
must build. It should be interesting.
So you need crunch bites,
you need to do to fix that practice
and thinks that break every cargo was
crunching your mouth to make,
to have the lead,
the creamy substances. It
will be a kind of boring. Um,
so I'll now we're going to have different
lectures, Matthew. So here you have,
I get the leaf rakes and
makes a high pitched sound,
which is much more like
crispy. Um, they're all,
they're going to be nuts. They're
going to be Christmas. Um,
they are all different mounts fields.
That really helped to
make a flavor imbalance.
Okay. Do you already a smell? Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Say the officer's juniors coming a
little bit to the, to the flavors and,
okay.
Imagine that the oil wouldn't be there.
The dish would be less interested. Right.
It's a smell that test.
Okay. Now we have a green
oil. No, just agreeing oil.
It is, um, uh, make from a
slack, Parsley and Tarragon.
Target has a lot of a slaver
and often when you make a,
an oil herb oil,
it's,
it's gonna Cause in some Brown Greens,
a color.
And then we blanch it first just in
water without salt and put it in,
put it out at the same time,
make it cold, very quickly,
squeeze out all the water. And then
we mixed it with 40 degrees Celsius,
uh, oil, uh, until it
was like this. And um,
uh,
it's a glorified which makes the,
the oil much more intensive than uh,
than you do.
It's a which is when it's wrong.
No.
Okay.
Look at what the color
does on the painting.
Oops.
Part of presentation.
So Am I, you are going
to eat this led well, uh,
you have to mix a lot of
things but it will happen.
Okay.
At the same time when
you ever taken is going
to connect
the terror gun,
the partially our fresh flavors and
they are often confounded with a,
with a sour,
that's the very important to distinguish
is freshness from Saudis fresh is
intolerance do go together once in a
while because then the oil like this,
it's just a freshman chief
job without the soundness.
So there's the reason it doesn't influence
these mafia on the contracting side,
that's two coat coating
but also gives fresh news.
Okay.
So now we will talking
about the carrots and um,
this is the purple carrots for me is
this, is, this is the example how to,
how to it seduce or 10
tastes. So juice, juice,
a carrot,
well it's not that difficult.
You just put it in.
He often for a long time
with a lot of a bay leaf,
I think this carrot had
about six Bailey's crushed.
So a lot of flavor can come out
of the babies, a lot of garlic.
Then we first blanches sewed up.
The plant cells can uh, can uh,
open open and then all the sweet juices
can caramelize and it's in the open on
160 degrees Celsius.
Uh,
sorry.
Next time I will have it would found
hearts in my head and then roast gross
gross. And it's going
to flavor like um, dope.
Yeah, licorice, licorice,
you know, liquors.
In Holland we are fond of liquids.
So this carrot is like licorice just
to carrots with three ingredients.
And I did it with, uh,
just the normal orange carrots and it's,
it's quite different.
It's more caramelized and it's
less intensive than the purple one.
So I have for everyone,
I have one piece yet,
so if you like it, just please
take one piece. Otherwise I don't,
we'll have enough.
Um,
and we have a whole carrots to combine
it with all the other flavors on the dish
show.
What is nice to uh,
yeah,
puts the,
I think one of the things in the astronomy
that people forget a lot is to cook
vegetables. Vegetables are a lot
of times and if you read them raw,
they are and their love more flavor to
find and carrots or in whatever vegetable
when you add temperature. And the
often here as well, when I'm here,
I'm often surprised all the things
that are even involved here,
Kale and sprouts and,
and much of these things,
I'm actually my turn for the better when
they've been cooked and then you can
eat them. Of course, uh,
uh, coal if you want.
But I'm cooking vegetables and the
lower temperatures, getting these,
getting these flavors out is a
very important side of the uh,
flavor story of Chicago for vegetables.
This is a freshly made tomato
puree from uh, tomatoes,
onions and cooks,
reduced all the water LRN until it stick.
And then we put it in the blender.
And then you have your own
fresh puree from goods ripen.
Yeah.
And uh,
this is the,
the color blocking how you see in the
fashion when you have an orange shirt,
uh, within the, uh, rec
trouser and you know,
so well and flavor is the same.
The characters very sweet and the
tomato is a little bit of acid.
So it will give much more life to a,
to old things.
Yup.
It's often when you miss something and
this then start with adding a little bit,
maybe some capable, all
little bits, a sour,
a tomato puree or a,
I soon as he is often forgotten
parts of the dish,
including better bitter in acidity.
Our thought that the people
don't like those things and uh,
they're kept away with,
for depth and for, um,
having great dishes.
You need a good addition of
some acidity in some bitterness.
Not too much, but a bit
slack. Salt. It's good to add.
Let's do all US fresh olives tried on us.
Okay. We have the, the fresh ones,
you know them,
it more flavors will come to you
when you are aware.
I would like to eating
but then see difference,
it's flavor,
the difference.
All the dried Kalamata olives and we
put in boats on the painting so we can
experiments. And what is happening
when you put out all the liquids?
It's,
it's very strange flavor.
I don't think you've ever flavored
like this and all it so intense.
It's a little bit better. Just a
little bit and a little bit more salty.
Okay.
What do maybe we'll do.
You could just a little bit.
So here and there. Yeah.
And uh, these ones we put liver togetherso
it's in the same area. So you
can taste boats. Yup. Okay.
Um,
let me see what I have the,
we do the same with the capers. We have
the fresh caper fuel note him. Yeah.
And when you dry the fresh capers
any often at 70 degrees Celsius,
so don't be in a hurry.
Uh,
the often is doing the job and you dry it.
You got to crunchy s it's ingredients.
It's very nice. It's very nice flavor.
We put us next to each other again.
So you can flavor the difference.
Yup.
Okay.
Of course you understand what you're
doing with um, can drying things in your,
your intensify flavors in it.
That's fine.
If for your flavors you're also
changing things. So you're,
you're reducing the sharpness of the
raw and the rock paper is a very sharp
facilities. Tasty tried one.
It's much more on the salty salt.
So you, the whole profile of
the Cape is changing by, again,
adding temperature
I think through, think of that's a
lot of work left the oven due to work.
You can do your own thing
while the oven is working.
You don't have to stand next to it.
You don't have to help it.
You don't have to look at it,
it just works by itself.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's from the Japanese kitchen,
a topping, uh, usually use for rice.
And I made it myself.
It's from a seaweed roasted sesame seeds,
white ones, the black ones
and Wasabi flavored ones, uh,
which, uh, you know, I need it in the, uh,
Tufts in the pen.
Um,
dried capers are also in it and
it's a really nice crunchy mix.
I'm going to put it on the,
on the side of the curve with the,
okay.
Where did Nisho because they're
a little bit French. Yeah.
And then,
uh,
you take a little bit and what's the
measle Kurtz and then with free Kaka and
you have a wonderful combination.
Okay.
Yup. Okay. So we are almost there
nuts.
Yeah.
And that's some things I will leave here
because it's getting a little bit too
busy on the,
we do
first we do the crunch,
we have a cracker.
I make prom,
a tapioca flour with saffron
and what are spread out,
dry it,
and then I deep fry it.
And the current is importance in a dish,
uh,
without, without a crunch.
This can be very, uh,
sometimes boring.
Even
the crunch we put on the saffron cream.
Okay.
Yeah. Just put it down. Put it in.
Okay. And we have to,
same with the seaweed.
Seaweed cracker also made from Tacos,
Tapioca and with crunchy
seaweeds we put on the,
we put it on the,
yeah,
on the missile,
not everywhere you're in there.
Then we have more,
we have the walnuts,
just plain bullets,
x different crunch,
then Endif or Dan,
uh,
the saffron crackers
and I put it crunch also.
What does the Kurds,
oh,
these are all elements that belong to
the drying components on the plate,
but evidently the nuts are
different in math field.
Gender crispness of the saffron and the,
um,
seaweed that'd be half of that one.
This is a very important one.
You know,
that the breath,
what's the cheese and the ham and then
the cheese is coming on the outside of
the breads, you know, that's,
and then you get that smell from
the caramelized cheese. Well,
this is the, the, the crunchy part of the,
of the [inaudible]. Sorry. It's
only gonna be sites of the toasty.
Yes.
This is wonderful.
You only need this when you flavor it
with the sweet potato and the tomato,
and then you have old Italian
Umami flavors. You can imagine.
I play dumb. You didn't
mention it's Parmesan, but, um,
most folks probably everybody knows since.
Why was it together with the motto?
Of course. It's a wonderful book. Oh yeah.
Pharmacy.
Yeah.
Just a couple. And then the rest
we do supports just a couple of,
yeah, hold on. Yeah.
Okay. We're almost there.
Uh, let me see. We have,
uh, this is very rich.
These are LG crackers,
not to LG from the television.
What's Lg from the
scene? Very, very strong.
Don't eat it. That's the first.
It's a beginning. Of course.
It stays very low in your mouth.
Okay.
Can you put some?
Yep. Okay. Let's see. One thing.
Yeah. The chef, because there is a
camera and I have a very awful.here.
Yes.
You see?
Okay. Then, uh, we leave just
a little bit separate. Um,
I started with the carrots and I
almost ends with the
carrots. But first, uh,
when we talk about no waste,
um,
you can make a powder from every
ingredients you can imagine.
So when you have a left
overs from veggies,
just dry them any often and then put
it in the like a coffee bean machine.
The small thing, you know what I'm here
like, right. Very quick one grinder.
Grinder. Yes. And then you can
make a wonderful power. So,
um,
I put some powder
sees that's taking place,
right?
Just to finish
up with green hair.
Yeah. It's awesome. Okay,
good. No, ours do a hell key hints.
Yeah.
Course.
So then we ends where we
started with the currents.
Uh, you see what's happening,
just a, the LGG powder.
It's a mixing, but two carrots,
nicer. Yup. That's what's happening.
The carrots a or I mates from when
you juice the carriage to the juicer,
then in the container,
your rudder, the pelvis,
we meaning just try to pull up and you
have a wonderful, uh, carrot powder,
which you can use in a
patisserie or in, uh, in,
in the Doh or dressings.
Okay.
All the sites.
Yeah.
Well,
that's actually has a lot of flavor.
Okay. Off of reading. Hers
are you have one. Okay.
Okay. I forgot one thing I
have to sign. Go to. Sorry.
I have to sign the
painting. Yes. So I say,
go on Google maps. Yeah.
So it's for you.
[inaudible]
I would like to invite you to come around
to painting and just experience all
the combinations.
So bon appetit.